yes we bring in Powell Beshear yeah how
and Russ are here it's like I'm getting
star strike oh there they are from the
TV show the weenie hell how and Russ how
are you say hello good morning how's it
going it's unbelievable make sure your
headphones and stuff are on yeah so yeah
I've been following your Instagram that
you guys have been kind of seeing New
York for the first time yeah the first
time taking the subway how would you
think BC yeah yeah any creepers any
creepers on the subway no not too bad I
didn't feel any hands ever anything so
is okay well welcome to the show we've
been obsessed with 90 day fiancé as I
think you both know from the beginning I
think you guys are one of the last
couples that actually are doing great I
mean the rest of them are kind of in
trouble right yeah it really does appear
what should mark you know right oh I
said [ __ ] watch the show our happily
ever after that's how you say I want to
know I'm obsessed with the guy from
Cleveland and the Russian bride I want
to know what happened to from your
season yeah we think I think I smoked
all the time yeah yeah yeah yeah all
right that's kind of cool cuz he's still
smoking cuz yeah I don't think he's
great yeah she can't enjoy that night I
met a young lady from another country
now when you want to come and visit did
you need a it was a hard for you to come
in but they're all laughing at me like
I'm Jim Jim thinks that because he has a
lady overseas that he just wants to hang
out with you yes and have her come for a
bit he thinks that there's like a lot of
red tape to get around somebody
vacationing yeah are you gonna play for
the Cayman be said you're gonna be a 90
day fiancé Jim no I don't want to marry
her no no no season and even our time
where she's from
she is from III say Colombia before but
she's not from Colombia
oh we're hot oh love me women are
awesome yeah um so are other members of
Colombians I mean yeah Colombian people
are delightful I know we are but is it
is it hard to get someone just to come
over for a vacation Japan you can go
with the tourist visa
you can't we apply for that twice and
got denied see that's what I'm worried
about wide
get tonight because I'm Colombian I mean
I guess you have to show a lot of
representation like I mean like they
have to have like a tie back to their
country so that make sure they're going
back to the country like their job I
stood money something like that studying
obviously they need to have like a like
something that makes their light like I
need to get back to my life yeah over
here
so they can't just come for like five
days I don't think so I would yeah until
you've approved and there's nothing you
can do it's really harder though that's
what I figured it was difficult to get
here on it she's not Colombian so you're
fine man why is Colombia the hard one
because this lady of yours have a job
though yes yes you know so wouldn't you
have to get back home every day so much
place of employment but yes you would
have to get back to work yeah
yes you would right back to work she's
going oh yeah work or pleasure what's
the purpose of this trip well yeah we're
just friends
yeah just having a friend come yeah but
I knew it would be harder than they said
I knew was gonna be more difficult than
they said it was gonna be
do you watch the like a reunion show and
realize that like your problems are
really not bad you know what I mean oh
like it's one of those other couples is
a complete disaster I'm on this show
which season we're talking about the
reunion show that you did on right now
the happily ever after show oh the
spin-off yeah yeah you know which are
they excited well they're not a couple
anymore though I mean remember Mohammed
and the large woman I do yeah yeah my my
favorite couple the watch now I haven't
watched since your season like I haven't
seen the updates I haven't seen any I
just I you know I don't know what's
happened in season two they're carrying
it that's for sure
yeah oh yeah yeah Mohammed decided after
getting married to meet another young
lady online and just moved to Florida
with her to Miami yeah
but Daniel is doing the same now who is
she's Danielle Oh went back for another
one oh yeah good for her that guy looks
like he's not from here too that's the
problem like Danielle ends up like oh I
got this date how's the threat coming up
to life
it's like this other like young in shape
guys with an accent yes and I noticed
like you doing yeah I'm like seriously
what's wrong with her I don't know I
kind of like I'm embarrassed like I got
hate mail from one of them oh yeah from
one of the girls from the show remember
the one with the tattoos and and she was
I forget who she was related to where's
she from don't remember Midwest the kid
did the magic show in one do you
remember that well I don't know about
Lou Louis Lewis and yes Louis and I
camera the action night I remember the
ex-wife with the tattoos oh yeah yeah
yeah sent me nasty [ __ ] you talk about
my kids all she didn't play games but I
wrote that I actually felt bad cause I
get I had the kids and we actually went
up talking it out online and she was a
fan so she I think she went up coming to
her show I don't know if we met or not
but we were gonna meet but we did but we
we worked it all out sometimes she just
spout off at the mouth not realize there
doesn't mean II people hear anything
you forget this real people attached to
I mean it's like it's one of those
things we just [ __ ] around the radio
as a gosh they're kids
hates me a little terrible yeah how did
you guys know Jean I know I felt really
bad how did you guys feel about your
lives like now everybody gets to have an
opinion on them like we get to go on the
radio and just like really fun in and
Bend and you know Twitter gets to talk
about it and all the stuff on Twitter
are me they are me unless they're
terrible ignorant and relentless that's
for sure they're mean to you pal
yeah sometimes why I think actually the
first season they were really mean they
were calling me like really bad names I
learned like really bad or like bad
words like what were they calling you a
gold digger and all this [ __ ] oh yeah
but I'm like right now people actually
are really related be nicer yeah and
this time now let's hear they've said
the next episode they think they let's
see what they think about it but he
didn't say gold digger now because
you're married for three years so it's
kind of hard to say that after all that
time it's like you can't claim that it's
just for a visa if you're still married
and you started doing those workout
Instagram videos booty war time after
and what's the booty workout videos went
up I'm assuming the criticism went town
G&R you're gonna do because with me I
certainly would yeah I'm trying cuz too
many people have been able to pull their
finger out
I really want to take my bed you want to
go back to being the one finger kid I
want to rip off I want to rip off
press-on nails you're gonna be my first
I trained you first okay yeah you know
it's funny uh the whole trainer thing
like I have two trainers that I use and
say it helps because it makes me
actually go because a lot of times I
don't want to go when like a [ __ ] I have
to cuz she's gonna be there and she's
gonna charge me if I don't go so I wound
up going but it's always a female right
yeah but it's only cuz it believe me I
don't want to male energy I do a male
energy all day it's all men I'm not I'd
made a point of you mister
but it's nice to have a female energy is
she had both happen is very attractive
yeah we're quit yeah that's so uh yeah I
dated one to actually want to tell you
one oh yeah yeah then she googled me and
that was the end of that like you like
what no yeah I was just not listening to
you right now
no no she's by working so is that what
you do you full-time training yeah I'm
doing it modeling acting in sometimes
like training people yeah no I know
you're doing the acting you were getting
some stuff which is good but I made a
video I was a hard place to act it's a
very there's not a lot of opportunities
and that's what the shows about
oh well yeah man she was trying to make
Ana take she wants to go to Miami right
yes yeah yeah yeah Miami New York or LA
one of those three places if you're
gonna act I'm about New York in LA
you don't like why don't you like Miami
mmm small bathing suits no I mean I'm
okay with that you're okay okay well
yeah what do you like Miami I think
there's more opportunity for me for my
job my career in LA okay which is what
oil and gas okay that make sense
what's it been like for you Russ the guy
who just works in like oil and gas and
stuff just a dude to now do this show
have the wife who now your wife wants to
be like a model-actress person like
you've been inundated with show business
and it wasn't at all never in my
anything in your wheelhouse was like
you're considering that no so with Nolan
gasps I've come from a conservative
background yeah I mean I'm a little
protective of it over yeah people in
Miami are crazy oh you know what it is
you're not used to the Latin guys in
Miami they behave a little differently
than like just the conservative
the Cardinal filter iSeries to just say
hello to me like while you guys are
together
no oh girl e that's gonna feel nice
though Windell i saying thanks and i'm
like this remind me of colombia like
real yeah but it's not shocking to you
though like here in miami you're not
thrown by it right no did you feel
comfortable when you went to Colombia to
visit her did you feel safe I mean I
live there
oh sure no she took me to places that I
was not oh great yeah like where like
like certain clubs or whatever like
downtown Bogota word yeah
crime is very prevalent did your any
problems Colombia safe his I'd say her
said her brother protected me with a
knife in front of him you know
yeah oh you had like you had an issue I
had no I wouldn't say an issue
she wanted a diem and they make him take
his belt like his Bella like you know
because it wasn't what he didn't how do
I say like that he wasn't able to wear
the veil in the study on because I just
took it as a weapon
yeah like a big belt buckles you can no
you can't wear a belt period at all like
that's a weapon like they would they pet
they patted me down three times you look
sloppy we get in irons everyone smoking
joints I mean they didn't care about the
drugs I just they just want to know
weapons around oh wow okay yeah yeah
bogan eyes a little that seems like it's
a little uh so kidnapping would scare me
so they're trying to take had it then
become a problem though because you want
to give your belt up I mean I just ask
someone that's a cover for me and it was
stolen in the end I was like hey watch
this for me and then gone never took off
bail again gone you guys gonna watch
your belt Colombian stadium the three I
want this belt when I get back into
aalverson you go back to remember is you
watch that belt no oh no home is
probably just from Target billet son
okay a big deal I get why they would
take it I mean if they think it's cuz I
can turn around some American gave it to
me turn around
they weren't actually looking at him
like a what are you doing here oh I'm
sorry
oh no yeah like I'm a target for sure
yeah it just come on but straight up
yeah what parts of Colombia is that not
a problem I mean there's different airs
of Bogota that you could go it's like at
your
they just I was asking about like a word
I can go and people suck it don't go to
Bronx like to the Bronx right and I'm
like it I want to go there
your honor no and this I can no you
shouldn't go there is the same in Bogota
but you with a beautiful woman to Italy
if you with like a 200 pound or 250
pound woman nobody would care you
probably they're kind of like a look at
that great American coming how did they
draw in truth imagine how did they feel
about that in Colombia that you were
with a Colombian woman no they looking
at him like me I'm like a normal okay I
was more the eye candy there they sell
the Colombian women like that like they
what they wanted to marry yeah they dig
it no I'd say go to Colombia you're
single then I don't know where I would
go though like where would I go I just
saw Darko's I don't know I'm very scared
to go there managing the others met
areas of metazine that you don't want to
ever go to there are right the cartels
still there yeah they are but do they
kidnap that I'll just kill you they pray
kidnap you yeah they've got the read
that whole piece turn you're scaring
their now they're not gonna go to
Colombia yeah this is not great for
Colombian tourists oh it's really good
to cut the haina
great beautiful city how about callie
callie's goods on the beach I don't
recommend Cali Colombia no that's not a
place that you do want to go Bogota is
fine in certain areas and may the genies
really good in Cartagena
but Cali woo not good now did you like
Marcos or no yeah I ready finish it I
like cartels about to come stuff to say
Cuddy what's that now they're just
talking about the cartel de Cali yeah
but they were bigger than as they say
meta-gene they're only say the Midian
cartel but they were Cali was yeah how
he's already dead how did you how did
what did you think when Jim Norton
reached out to you about using one of
your bathing suits for his iPhone video
Pickens fee for them all when the ice
bucket challenge was a thing Jim did it
in a POW from 90 day fiancé
bathing forgot that I was willing to pay
the suit I thought I brought that myself
oh my gosh there is nothing not Russ
when you see that you know does that
makes a little bit of your insecurities
ko I'd go away no
I don't think that what a mushy man and
his wife stop who are you hanging out
with well I don't know I think it was
Hitler use yeah if you want to you have
a good boobs though thank you very much
shadow really did make me look a lot
bigger today than I am the audience
I was club so he cares yeah no this is
bad
yeah yeah at least you had the body to
pull it off yeah exactly what yeah and
there he is
oh that's me huh it was really nice
actually we have a great time that was
fun yeah you came to the show it looks
better on me yeah you look better than
anything next time maybe he to where the
other part well there was a scene on
exactly the bottom would you like to
fill out the bottom so that bikini I
certainly would
there was a scene uh during that first
season of the show when you were in
Ross's house and you walked down to
breakfast in a teddy yeah was that legit
yeah it was yeah do you remember I just
it's comfortable you know I don't see a
big deal about it we didn't go for that
no no we didn't approve of Maui yeah bad
yeah I was just meeting like for the
first time he's caring so I didn't know
actually how they were and now I know so
I to wear something more like yeah I
guess yeah the parents a bit more
conservative a religious your parents
yeah oh they are okay yeah your dad has
to pretend to have a problem with it
like I don't want to see that no no no
we don't want to live in the Bible Belt
what do you expect yeah so what are you
gonna do it you're gonna stay in Miami I
would prefer of those three I think the
LA or New York is by far the bet I grew
with you I think that of those three
even what you want uh New York or Los
Angeles Miami is good for like modeling
you know like acting I will say New York
but yeah anyway on should I like fit in
in Miami I mean this yeah - let my LA
tène people I thought I did yeah but
isn't isn't it harder to stand out if
there's all Miami models like if there's
a million these that is not good yeah
but you know what you're unique you know
it's like exactly look where I am a flop
true no I just I think I can make it I
already have a good opportunities in
there already so okay I know
on this week's episode on the preview
for next week's episode it involved Pao
doing some topless work
it's my pictures he's not topless but
you were not wearing a top Howie was
worried my hands right
you didn't actually show nipple no no no
I know I wouldn't go that far
no but they were out yeah they're
implying nudity yeah yeah how'd you feel
about that Russ the biggest thing for me
was it was she never no consented with
me about it let you know that it was
gonna have your word about it I mean in
the end the pictures look great she
looks beautiful
right I mean make some money but you got
to talk to the boss first in my opinion
I'm the bust oh okay that's that's where
there is a difference and you know who's
the boss
right right right she you're the boss of
your own titties you're saying it's not
power me so you are do you have that
struggle like hey man I you know in my
house growing up the man was in charge
and you know put up with this yeah
independence huge food shift on on what
I've grew up on that's for sure yeah
that's what that's what happened with
you I mean we had a lot more dominant
and this one's got a very dominant
personality yeah you know I saw I saw on
an episode Russ gave her like a
sentimental birthday gift he gave her a
nerf gun and she was like what the [ __ ]
is it
seriously yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah why
on earth why he was trying to go with
the toss toss toss thing you know yeah
right I thought about getting a real gun
but after even getting the nerf gun
first thing she did she shot me in the
head so it's really give her a real good
I don't think so it was it was really
uncomfortable though because it was like
you know he was like oh here's this fun
birthday get me she's like this is
[ __ ] just like threw it aside
exactly what do you want in front of all
is like friends and everything different
stupid guildford a gun I got a little
crystal necklace right like come on a
toy she was wearing in the in the scene
yeah he gave me a necklace but like at
the end of the night when all my friends
was around me if I could give me a bat
[ __ ] I think yeah it's shitty gonna like
it so you start with a gag gift vinh yen
with the nice gift that's a little Ernie
let's see what he's gonna give you next
year
give the jewelry in front of the friends
right cuz that all your friends are like
really
give you deadbeat he gave you a nerf
that's what that's how they perceived it
right that's for sure okay I here with
this happy to knowest I like it was what
is this and I was like something for his
childhood and I'm like I did something
you forget that I'm Colombian my cat
come on don't play with this yeah that's
right that's right
and genic mutant pick up on the fact
that you know toss toss you put the gun
no I'm looking I'm over that I don't
know what toss toss means that's what
she dies but they got like she put your
fingers like guns and goes toss toss
toss toss celebration you know it's like
a test I said this is so good but I'm
over that yeah but you weren't
celebrating that day no no no you were
not I got put down
yeah wittingly and how long did it take
you to use of the fact that instead of
like like when some day Louis if someone
laughs laughs they've instead of HHA
they put J AJ a and so jaja jaja I still
read it as judges so one actually told
me like a hate you know though in a Mary
Kay is late with an age and I'm like
what steel Columbia right you have not
fully embraced the American come on I
can't do that I want to be in Spanish
with the HHA just like a lot like a lot
of it come on Spanish laughs that's it
how it's been like three years or
whatever yeah
does pal fit more in at home with your
friends and all that stuff are they
still her spine I wouldn't know what to
shake his head how is vomiting this yah
this thing to me cuz like I've seen like
a struggle for like I'm the dominant man
and the you're like well I'm not
changing but I've never seen it go for
30 years like it's just it's always
there it's never like angry but it's
always just like now what I can do it
that way it's just Abney present it's
very odd we fight behind the doors you
do we got to get out of Oklahoma it's
pretty it's pretty clearly I don't know
even even you're finally lay out yeah I
mean Oklahoma's my home and it always
will be but maybe get home to visit the
night of Istra visit you little stick of
Oklahoma cruising yeah when I went to
Columbia lived there I wanted to get out
and then the job brought me back to
Oklahoma so it's just like this is my
job this is my opportunity is what we're
dealing with
and then here we are now looking for
other opportunities so where do you so
you go out on rigs right like don't you
do like oil rigs and stuff I did yeah
okay certainly if you haven't been
following apparently heaven now I'm
unemployed right now okay though all the
oil industry is in shambles I'm the one
working with the economy's crap right
now especially in Oklahoma so what else
can you do we got to get out of Oklahoma
oh it's out of there okay and go back to
where there's aura because now powers
got to sit there and do shitty like
Raceway modeling and she's got to show
up to little hike like races and be like
here's this here's that you have to be
on your fever so many hours and like a
lot of people just staring at you in my
creepy way and I'm like I know I'm too
old for this what's Raceway miles I mean
you go to a Raceway and just do it these
are pretty much what it sounds like
you're on yeah you just stand there and
like you got like some product across
your chest and then everybody just kind
of stares at you but it's your job so
yeah I like to give the trophies and all
those things sometimes he's fun but he's
like at the end of the night you just
don't want to do that anymore yeah I get
that would be a little draining I mean
I've done it before and you done Raceway
most certainly oh that's so cool I'd
recognize the name yes
I probably wasn't using a professional
term yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm a bit of an
outsider to the whole culture so how
long have you been without a gig mmm
that's six months now okay yeah so is
there like hope on the horizon or what I
think we got to get out and that's why
she's pushing from Miami establishing a
residency somewhere else will help me
find something but you know oil and gas
wise there's nothing in Miami for me
there here's what you do though go to
Miami and it's like this wacky
fish-out-of-water thing and then the
show is like you know Russ and PAL go to
Miami and you've got a rope in this trip
and then you get paid to do the show
that's your job now you're a reality
star by profession now I have to fit in
in Miami you know because it's a lot of
late that'll be the reality right there
right right
biggest famish in Miami I see you see a
lot yeah it's hard to find actually
people speak English in there so you
would for you like you've probably
learned all you forget all the English
that you learned but there's also like
God well
- a lot of Haitians down there in Miami
there's a Miami and probably talked at
the comedy club and they said that you
know they had to move it just because
the you know Haitian guys were shown up
in heckling where the Haitian guys bad
hecklers yes I imagine we're not
pleasant like they were like hardcore
yes yeah they think they were like
[ __ ] thugs brutal
yeah that's what hurt oh my god so what
else is gonna is gonna go on this season
on the on the show a lot of drama yeah
yeah yeah do you watch the other seasons
we have with the different courts with
with the uh-oh
right over after portion right so you
watched it so I got a passport through
you know yeah and he's hardened out
every time he gets like even worse and
more somewhere with a couple yeah oh
they're terrible Thanks thank you Wow
seriously cuz they were like it's the
first season everyone kind of ended okay
and they're like we can't we can't keep
doing TV like this there's got it we
need more disasters they are all six got
married right if I remember correctly
all six couples I think so I don't think
anyone has never got married on the show
Oh shoddy words what's happening no he
got his play at night they're not
together anymore which one Danijela
Mohammed no there's no there's no marry
there sorry America even in super in
like my mom is just doing this thing
yeah they're living in separate states
so he's like hey come on they're
separated they're not divorced there's
no legal well it's not of course
nobody's deal like hey that's not a
couple so what's the what's the green
card laws now like are you like power
you like good to go now as an American
or do you or like like if you separated
no the first one is two years resident
and now the one that I'm waiting is for
10 years seems to be here for 10 years
no he will let her stay for 10 years oh
but after I get that one I can actually
apply for the citizenship
also I can become an American band okay
Russ is there anything in the back ear
head that's like look I know when the
next cutoff point is okay that's three
years is a long time maybe that's why
I'm trying to hold back from Miami right
yeah what will move to Miami after I
know this is locked in yeah can you guys
compromise and go Oklahoma to LA and
then if you like that then you go to
Miami I don't have any
neither am I supposed to do I don't have
any contacts or anything Miami I do so
it's like a better option for me to go
to Miami instead of my life so are you
getting good gigs acting and stuff yeah
I needed a commercial which was great I
like I do a local commercial in Oklahoma
I have done others with the different
companies and the little role that I did
for the US Army there is an interactive
filming oh yeah that wasn't a commercial
that was actually like for a movie okay
which oh my gosh I feel so embarrassed
with my English why I'm good which is
fine he's hard to see myself like it oh
because I was really nervous when I was
doing it and like oh I feel so
embarrassed did they tell you to do it
better no that's like it that is what it
is I was like one of the first gigs when
she first started doing in Oakland City
yes I always get nervous I always like
to put down on myself because come on
he's a big boy who's the Freak I forgot
there was another girl was a model too
who was the little tiny girl although
Brazilian girl yeah oh yeah she was
super cute yeah she was lovely oh yes
you think I'm concerned she's married to
a Mormon so oh that's right so that
she's holding her back quite a bit yeah
yes remember there kissing was very
awkward on television everybody I think
you could actually yeah were you happy
with the way you were portrayed or maybe
or the way Powers portrayed because I
felt like and I was happy with it but
every every scene on that first season I
felt like POW was either in like a
bathing suit or a teddy in the kitchen
or whatever it was like were you happy
with with the way it came out the first
season no I wasn't why not but I think
I'm actually getting like more like
bikini shots in this season and a you
didn't you didn't you didn't like that
you're in a bikini the entire no the
first season all's I kill I don't know
like a drunk person or something like
nothing I'm not but was that in the
editing or was that just what you were
doing I just like tequila right right
but no I just what too much like yeah
didn't like it that much the first one
this one I'm like I'm really happy with
what's going on in this season I mean I
feel like they were pushing hard on like
this season
they were asking her we went with they I
don't think they even showed this one
but we did a I fly where you do the
indoor skydiving right every wanting to
hold down his Dipper make it look sexy
she's like no this is not sexy outfit at
all we know dude come on I feel like
they're pushing sexy on this this season
then yeah summers knows that much you
know what that's got that if they're
pushing for you to do that means you
probably have a great career in modeling
and acting and things like that right
that's sexy away right yeah that's kind
of sleazy TV all right sugar cans while
you're skydiving it only shows a dress
when they starting and I love breasts
but not when someone's skydiving
plus it's so obvious what you're
watching it's like there's POW skydiving
with hurt it's just like all out and
it's a language this is obviously done
with with the television audience in
mind like there's no way she would have
made that choice come on that's like the
least comfortable thing you could have
done yeah well my husband actually said
no hell no yeah when can people watch it
and we're excited and see I've not seen
the new one but I will watch are you
really
I will watch it yeah it's good you can
watch it a Sundays at 10:00 p.m. on TLC
okay and I remember telling you guys
about the first season and being like
this is it's like the craziest thing
you've ever seen on TV and it's become
like one of TLC's biggest franchises no
it is
I like season four still I'm still on
board so I watch that so I do on set I
watched the new one and then I watched
the happily ever after people blame you
actually saying like I'm watching this
show because of Jim Norton come on yeah
the season one I watched with you guys
but I never watched after yeah no you
just go to happily ever after happily
ever after no I was hoping the film crew
or be in here and we get on TLC but no
just no no look I already did this if
the shows on it's over like they filmed
it oh that I just always fix it they
filmed the show on rut radio oh okay
yeah I don't know how all right well
thank you resting pal